So I'm thinking about hardware devices
as essentially physical representatives
of these cloud services.
Which makes them very different than traditional
consumer electronics.
So historically a company made an electronic product.
Say a turntable. Then they found
people who would sell it for them.
Then they advertised it heavily. And people bought them.
And that was the end of their relationship
with that customer until they were able to convince
that person to buy another one.
So the entire value of that relationship
had to be packaged within the device itself.
My pet theory is that
that's why they used to put heavy metal plates
into consumer electronics. So they would feel like
they were getting more value out of them.
With the Internet of Things, the sale of the device
is actually just the beginning of the relationship.
It's not the end of the relationship,
it's the beginning of the relationship.
And the physical thing actually holds almost no value
for either the consumer or the manufacturer.
Value now shifts to services. And the devices:
the device is the software applications.
You know, the website, the apps
that are used to access them.
I call those things avatars.
They're physical representatives of a thing that's
up in the clouds right? I also want to steal it back
from the VR people. That was totally wrong.
So anyway, a camera becomes a really good appliance
for taking photos for Instagram.
My TV becomes a really nice way
to display Instagram photos that you don't have to log
into every time; and you can show people at a party.
A phone becomes a really convenient way
both to take photos and to check your friends' photos,
photo streams (or Kanye's) when you're on the road.
Hardware, the physical things, in this situation
becomes simultaneously more specialized
and de-valued as people
see through each device to the service it represents.
People don't care about the device.
They care about the service.
The avatars exist in order to get better
value out of the service.
Amazon really gets this. So here's a telling older ad
from Amazon for the Kindle. What it's saying is:
look, use whatever device you want. We don't care.
As long as you stay loyal to our service.
You can buy one of our specialized devices
that we lose money on every time (on purpose)
because the value is in the service.
But you can use some other way to access our services,
and we don't have to lose money on the device.
When Fire was launched, it was originally "Kindle Fire".
Now you know you have Fire Stick and Fire Phone
RIP (not really in IP) but anyway...
those of you--only like two of us would get that joke--
when Fire was released Bezos even called it a service.
It is not a device.
It is not a thing. It is a service.
Amazon Dash is a service that's enabled
by a dedicated device--so this is a real thing.
So you can buy a washing machine from Whirlpool
or GE that will reorder its own supplies.
It will re-order its own Tide
when it's running out of Tide.
Will re-order its own bleach when it's running
out of bleach. You can buy this today.
This is enabled by Amazon's Dash service.
And the reason that Amazon made this
is so that they wouldn't have to make these devices--
you know, shipping all that metal is really expensive.
Why should we, making it,
why should we take the hit on doing
the R & D for a washing machine
when we can take all the profit by selling the Tide?
So Amazon also, for things that don't speak (to)
the Amazon Dash service, they'll sell you a button for it.
So here's a Tide button.
This is a network computer you can buy
for $5 whose entire purpose is to order you Tide.
Every single time you push the button
it will order you Tide and only Tide.
Here you can pass it around.
Don't be ordering me Tide!
So... if you look here you can see...
the top one is macaroni and cheese
the bottom one is mints.
These are services that are effectively preparing you
for infinitely automatically
replenishable macaroni and cheese.
It's a macaroni and cheese service
that you will buy into so you never have to think
about buying macaroni and cheese again.
The margins on this are insane.
So most large-scale Internet of Things
products are service avatars like this.
They use specialized sensors and actuators
to support a service. But they have very little value
or don't even work at all without the supporting service.
It's just like your phone.
Your phone if you cancel your contract
doesn't really work.
I mean the Wi-Fi works, but
theoretically doesn't really work.
When SmartThings was acquired by Samsung,
they clearly state their service offering up front.
And tell you very little about what the stuff does.
What the service offers is that they will help you
be home wherever you are.
They don't tell you how.
That's what they're going to do.
What does their hardware do?
You don't know. You don't care.
You shouldn't care.
Compare that to X10, their spiritual predecessor,
who's been around since the Tandy color computer.
All X10 tells you about its white plastic boxes
is what they are. Not what they will accomplish for you.
Like I don't even know if there is a service.
Why should I care that they have "modules"?
What the!? I shouldn't and I don't.
So I think the real value that connected services offer
is their ability to make sense of the world on our behalf.
To reduce cognitive load
by enabling people to interact with the world
with devices at a higher level than simple data.
Than simple telemetry.
At the level of intentions and goals
rather than data and control.
Humans are not built to make sense
of huge amounts of data
across many devices.
Or to articulate our needs as systems
of mutually interdependent components.
Computers are great
at all that shit.